now police have arrested a fifth man in
their investigation into the
disappearance of the student nurse awami
davis she was last seen a month ago
while in south london well joining me
now is our correspondent madeline
radcliffe for more on this good morning
to you maddie so uh what's going on with
the investigation just tell us where we
are right now
good morning well awami davies was seen
on this road at derby road in croydon
south london she was picked up in the
early hours of the morning on the
thursday the 7th of july by cctv in a
shop and also by the cctv camera you can
see behind me here on derby road
and she was seen in that cctv the police
have since released those pictures as
part of their investigation
there was a later that morning 7am an
unconfirmed sighting of her as well on
nearby clarindon road but
that was three days after she left her
family home in essex and the
metropolitan police's specialist crime
unit is now investigating trying to work
out what happened to her a month ago now
over a month ago and they have now
arrested a fifth person as part of those
investigations a 27 year old man on
suspicion of kidnap that brings the
total to three people arrested on
suspicion of kidnap two people arrested
on suspicion of murder and four of those
people have now been bailed
but the police say they are still
investigating it is very complex case
they are trawling through cctv they say
but they have renewed their appeals to
members members of the public for
information